Yerkes has been waiting for this and
waiting to redeem themselves but this
also puts more pressure on them
especially tweets like this yeah York
City has been scaring they were all
making calls as well as concert if we
don't get out all hell is gonna rain on
us from both well yeah all hell is doing
around yeah I know you want to think
about actually it's just gonna tilt me
[Applause]
[Music]
look at the beautiful crowd here in
Wuhan getting ready for here so is the
scary thing with SKT even when you feel
like they're petting the unkillable
demon king aka faker in three out of the
last four years song Eclipse unluckily
has adapted get a look at misfits gaming
as well as team w/e as they gear up for
a class on the stage here in Wuhan or
misfits this will also be their first
international a pirate was on the way
down but expect was studded and position
to use an oldie yet to run away from the
choke at first just like we ran away
from the potential fight at the replay
can't wait to catch today we know so
much is on the line very for really
honest so actually think that c9 has a
good chance of advancing 204 finalists
um I I think we need at least one any
team in determined to make it more
interesting and they're the best any top
impact and I really hope that impact
playboy and the team and oh yeah I think
they have a good chance
[Music]
yeah it was shake yet first when he died
he got caught off by the sequani
multiple times is what its gonna look
like so built that double mountain break
they plated parent thank you very much
guys
indeed joined here by Zhao who after a
front 10 has big wave Iorg in the first
game so first off I want to ask you that
who this is always a very stressful game
as it is the first one of the tournament
and the early gaming was try it rough so
what was the key to take about spinner
Bachchan mortals with their win over
fantatic defense fanatics a fantastic
way and perks lives up to his word shied
to a silencing Wuhan quote-unquote fatty
squishy
Sanders for is so important iPhone I boy
is everyone just kind of slowly walking
towards them
they're fighting it 280 carry who has no
last whisper right this is like a much
earlier in the game back everyone I am
Julian patient crazy dogs got flanked by
judge who got Lisa and Zack rusty 5
winning top one we won straight up so
that was kind of our mindset just
running through SAT fool up on his
famous rack side right there everything
was great please just cut the tape right
here now what we've learned about SKT
that they're basically Terminator 2 to
the side of immortals and long through
their eyes are back towards the band
with no spider vailable it's actually so
easy as well no way out oh is it a
flashing look it as a way out how is it
that you're able to play with so much
confidence on the world stage
[Applause]
[Music]
anyway what are you fine gene so boy saw
that somebody finally we have the
struggling fanatic they went oh three in
week one still looking to strike back
after a couple of days of rest and it's
gonna be a tough road for them if
they're gonna make it out of this group
they have to essentially run the table
they have to be able to take down long
too and you're hoping that other teams
lose all their game that's the two info
tiebreaker yeah we're gonna do be doing
a lot of shuffling probably until we can
slot everyone correctly c9 they slid in
here at the end Katie help them out
let's see where they end up team w/e
will be their matchup for cloud nine
still w/e look incredibly strong but
that is maybe 11 we have a traffic jam
there orange is like we'd like to play I
want to confirm just for the viewers
that this is correct c9 vs w e just so
there's no pretty topsy-turvy for the
five man synchronize flat for TSM will
signal their potential and I think for
them hopefully their final entrance onto
the rift I know you've probably already
heard of what happened to the North
American team so far what seeing him
just sort of jump around on a choke app
and like to stomp around do that one
more time jump around yeah stuff around
like that look at the final game of the
day determines the first seed out of pit
group let's yeah throw the pants throw
everything out the window it's game time
ladies and gentlemen
alright that's enough from us for now
let's head over to the chassis's they
get in the annual tale gigabyte Marines
they're not quite strong enough to
the game so as though just feeding fuel
into the fire recoger called a double
drop that's the triple he's looking for
the quadrats let's get down as well
pencil could come out no way is hook
before it they will attend is there it's
in legendary eleven kill tristana and
off the mid thank the pizza [__] my
Marines are gonna take the galaxy's
I say one last thing to all the top
laners in the world keep this in mind if
you lose it's not your fault but the
tumbler spot okay Wow I think this is a
winnable game for fnatic yeah look good
the circle is speaking in a has always
done well we blonde but not so well week
two but good thing for us and cloud nine
is we're heading into week because we
played in two planes so we have nothing
to worry about
[Applause]
sometime if you do think you're holding
over and big of course but again when
you are Yasuo player you have to just
look at the one member it's one of you
Anna Colden Maverick round-robin how we
feel it ready to put the Y in analysis -
yeah that's about right
great I said you gotta give me at least
I call like a hashing as they all like I
still make in my colony it's like one
cloud I'd ward off the bat down in the
bottom by the river
other than that they're checking all the
fresh with their skill shots there
they're just cautiously blue vodka as
many awards as wins for North America
too
the business a hundred percent deserve
their quarterfinal spa and TSM do not
know congratulations
crumbs as well for his perfect
prediction of number one and two spot
thank you thank you
you're not gonna finally a lot of bets
going on with you the one that I want to
talk about is the one for the chicken
nuggets Oh huh
I mean can't you just go get some
chicken nuggets why would you have to go
that far to get them from your coach it
tastes more beautiful when someone buys
you something and gives it to you it's
like when you make your own food right
if I just go and buy my chicken nugget
to say you know an average day the
office right but my coach buying me a
hundred chicken nuggets like that's
motivation right there that's gonna make
me try out in public right now waiting
nice ruptured get that long range for
trick so we can get the damage in and it
looks like expection get Hank early but
the damage won't feed their root collar
just a little closer and he stays alive
Chuck's the post an early shield comes
up they stay alive but that was bashed
the damage just isn't there for him
Levite it's a danger of his own it now
he retreats back into the bounce Cody
Sun pop the da ah no way no way because
[Applause]
trip
does have flash he comes back around 50
in the flatlands flooding them no sir no
there is turret architects one shot but
there's the damage chaplain and they're
gonna get first blood coming through the
rim prison in time bow belt sir
400 gold Richard II does final assets
heart now a three-part late for flash
wolves go to the nuke see over the wall
they're gonna get a quick hit over I'm
like gee who's planning this one before
they think nothing is there because of
the ward right through the uprights this
is absolutely ridiculous from team w/e
the only time they work proactive is the
map when they lost dragon and they went
right back to that area the vision
pregame control and ever since they have
not lost it the second inhibitor turret
going town with its in his double it
flashes the wrong way he ends up giving
it doesn't kill over the gwe kinetic
really have a pretty easy checklist as
far as how to how to finish out this
game now well maybe not so easy to get
the blue buff he'll eventually get it
tell us about sinful acts done Oh
apparently doesn't work I guess he
didn't do that
looking for the big play almost
there is no a teapot the barrier make
them certain the fall the eggs for SK
Telecom's you it's much harder for him
to clear those in multi camps curious
though knowing the coz started the red
side he doesn't have that inmate and he
also messes up the patients on the globe
so it resets not a good look for x-men
that mold aru mystic now in a big big
trouble feather storm comes out Betty
actually gets pushed to the right side
from monsoon but that's the heel for
mystic Betty they may be able to take
him down but the hits come in from the
bend and now they're on a sword art
another field picked up in that Lane and
bring it a knock him down and here comes
the next one Jensen flick to the falls
well fee to be grabbing himself another
one his first kill that game five to one
now for launcher Roy I'm Alex geez been
spots of chicks that stone before this
one now all of a sudden trick is is used
to flash didn't really get anything for
we can have aggression our she's trying
to get very touchy up top lane there's
the top bot if I'm gonna land for sure
there's no way on anymore to close on he
pops Britain goes up on the leap and
Mikey's gonna wake up man you gotta be
kidding me she's not gonna die
that boy don't look at the damn it Janet
Archer survives the account and I'll
leave idle um be too because want to
chase need farther but that's two
flashes down for one of the surviving
retail and here comes her eyes ultimate
teleports behind you nothing person
they'll kid and immediately how is this
gonna work
you're teleporting it took Cassiopeia a
hundred times out of a hundred we all
have a question mark beams going down on
the LSS after this maybe with Barrett
take it out it kept to get done the way
to the pathetic that's the courtesy to
play
[Music]
has played nearly a perfect game here
they have the flash down on Phobos as
well to try to get out
smithy cannot miss this have started up
this Barrett I don't feel like he isn't
important to give it up Newton so much
tennis to double its they're here
something doesn't probably Denny another
on the bronzer that abut 14 Sin City
again John Smith's close to back away
the holy no bulbs up there a little too
far
power of evil takes him down from contra
cookies to take use member
welcome for Johnson to Vegas the book
shield though when Chris comes up from
on black he's trying to make it happen
he's not gonna make it go through the
shots come through and sneaky takes him
down this with HQ moment but the problem
is is that brother double it brother
West and Robert wildturtle cinemas
regards everyone's gonna have a box-like
vision on today who is your moment
well double that still has his flash
from yesterday dead dad I'm so sorry it
was playing right there in front of me I
had to pick the poplin does support
going down 3d for immortals was to run
away but fnatic they want this one the
chase for the public not quick the blade
color range and just barely missing
father that my amethyst don't want to be
done to look for the kill breath that's
gonna come in
Baggins is the elder dragon reset the
Goonies still has free time into the
base
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]